let's stop there you know what I woke up  this morning thinking about a public  execution I did I really did but for now  I'll settle for this yeah sweet little  you know who's gonna get in first so  while you're on the clock  this means code did you not get that  that's the universal sign it was I not  clear heaven's sakes what did you make  of that there's so many universal  symbols this is one that's obviously not  communicable what's this dial it down  that's dial it down what's this  get out no smaller okay here like  disease  here's I'd like dessert that would be  nicer to say this would be  I won't do this anyone pay the bill not  pay the bill this would be that would be  pay the bill this is where's my cheque  where's my cheque please my cheek